- [Mark] All right.
Peaches?
- Yeah, my name is Peaches.
- [Mark] Peaches?
Peaches, where'd you grow up?
Where are you from originally?
- [Peaches] California.
I'm a resident of California.
- [Mark] What part?
northern or southern?
- [Peaches] northern.
- [Mark] northern, okay.
- [Peaches] I grew up in L.A.
- [Mark] That's southern.
- Oh.
- [Mark] Okay, so tell
me about your childhood.
You had both of your
parents when you were young?
- Yes.
- [Mark] How was your childhood?
I actually had a white
childhood to be honest.
I was privileged.
- [Mark] Good childhood?
No trauma, no abuse, nothing like that?
Pretty good then?
- Mm-hmm.
- [Mark] Both mom and
dad were in the picture?
- Mm-hmm.
No mom, she died, but.
- [Mark] Your mom died when?
- 2007?
January 26th, 2007.
- [Mark] How old were you?
- I was in elementary school.
I had no capacity, but
I didn't know anything.
I don't even know what was going on.
- [Mark] You told me
something on the street
about your grandmother was your
pimp or something like that?
- Yeah, everybody knows that.
- [Mark] When did you start
working as a sex worker?
- Eleven years old.
- [Mark] Eleven?
How did that happen?
- It's some tragic stuff.
- [Mark] Like what happened?
- Some personal stuff.
- [Mark] That's what we talk about here.
- Okay.
So, where's the video going to again?
- [Mark] The entire planet basically.
- Oh, hell no.
So you got me up here
looking like a fucking fool.
And I already told you, just look at this.
Oh no.
Wait, they gonna see me wearing this?
Oh, in the hood?
- [Mark] You don't wanna do it?
- Oh, you at least gotta call it a DP?
I mean, discipline, honey.
They're gonna think I
talked to the police.
In the streets of Frisco, honey,
whack is hard for a tranny.
For me, I get it easy, 'cause I'm young.
- [Mark] What's the hardest part?
Period, I'm gonna give you
five minutes of some real shit,
and then I'm gonna get
my money and bounce.
Period.
- [Mark] Let's hear it.
- My name is Peaches,
I'm an OG prostitute.
I've been in the game
since eleven years old.
My mother died at two months old.
My grandmother raised me.
Boo and Denise, you know what?
Got addicted to black-tar
heroin at fourteen years old.
From fourteen years old, all
the way up I stopped school.
My aunt came, anonymous name.
She changed my life, tried to.
Was there for me all the way,
but I was just stuck in life of the game.
'Cause I never had really
experienced relapse.
I was just always hustle,
hustle, hustle, hustle.
But then you know that.
But I'm 18 years old.
My birthday is on December 2nd, yes honey.
I was born and raised
in Stockton, California.
My residency is unknown
because I'm homeless right now.
And I'm 18, I tried to get services,
but nobody wants to help me.
I'm a prostitute.
I work on Skip the Games and
that's how I make my money.
And right now I'm just
really down low right now.
- [Mark] Yes, you are.
- Because I don't fuck with the police.
You either ten toes down in the game,
or you fly and you die.
When you live this life,
it comes with regulations.
This shit ain't easy.
No human being on this
Earth feels comfortable
selling their body every single day.
Honey, I just got out the hospital, honey.
I have a stomach bug, one
of my tricks gave to me.
And I had to have sex with him
without protection because,
it was either that or me
fall asleep in the rain.
But yeah, right now, yes,
this is me and you can find me
on Skip the Games, I go by Peaches.
My phone number.
209-306-4345.
Please do not call if it is not about me.
- [Mark] Hold on.
You use drugs at all?
- Yes, I do, crystal meth.
- [Mark] Have a seat.
- What?
- Can I hit my piece, though?
- [Mark] I'll pay you a little extra.
- Oh so, a little extra like what?
- [Mark] Crystal meth.
Tell me about crystal meth use.
- First time did it, paranoid.
You know hallucinate,
was found unresponsive.
And you can look me up on the net.
(name censored)
That's my real name.
Yes honey, and I was found in the day.
Thank God I was tweaking,
and remembered my aunt's number.
- [Mark] You've been arrested before?
- Yes I have.
- [Mark] Have you been in love before?
- Right now I don't
really know what love is.
Because anybody can hang out and make you
fall in love right now and
drop down to the knees.
And what, please, 'cause you like what?
'Cause any man on this Earth would never
pass up no, you know what.
But I'm gonna leave that to the side
because me as a person, as a who I am?
Working girls, they risk their
life every night out here.
- [Mark] Have you had any
bad stuff happen to you?
- Multiple times.
- [Mark] What kind of stuff?
- When you come in here
you experience rape.
Abandonment, rob, kill, anything.
Anything is possible in the street.
You know that song?
♪ When the night falls,
loneliness calls. ♪
Honey, how I live in these streets,
I don't walk the streets in fear.
I walk the streets with
the faith of God, honey.
When it's time for me to go,
it's time for me to go, period.
But until then, every night I go home,
everyday I wake up, okay.
Peaches girl, you better
give it a good one
because today might be the
last day you breath again.
Tomorrow's not promised.
Honey, I died two times and came back.
I'm here for a purpose.
Anybody on the street?
I take off my shoes for anybody.
I will go fully butt naked and
give out who really need it
at the end of day, because I
know deep down God was looking
out for me and he'll look
out for me when I'm up.
I don't have to answer to Him.
Because I'm helping His people now.
I'm here for His people
and I ain't here for you.
You see how I look right now?
Look young.
But if somebody walked
over right now, dopesick.
I would give them some, period,
because I have a good heart.
- [Mark] Did you sleep at all last night?
- No, honey.
- [Mark] When was the last time you slept?
- Well, two days, well, three days.
But that's my little short one.
Long time been up.
My last one was what?
A week and a half.
Because the crystal, the
crystal keeps you up up.
Yeah, but I've been laced
with fentanyl multiple times.
Fentanyl is a drug that's like heroin,
but it's just a downer.
- [Mark] You were trying fentanyl,
or your meth was laced with it?
- Laced with it.
'Cause when you melt
crystal it turns yellow,
but when you melt fentanyl
baby it goes straight black.
- [Mark] You can kill yourself that way.
- Yes, I know.
- [Mark] You gotta be careful out here.
- I know.
- [Mark] What's more important
to you, love or money?
- Neither, breathing is
more important to me.
Whatever the case may be.
I get a high living, baby.
So is that it?
Because my time is up because I got to go.
- [Mark] So what's the most
important lesson you've learned?
- Never ever, ever, ever
forget your self-worth.
My advice to people?
You live every day like it's your last.
Don't ever, ever, ever
underestimate yourself.
Don't ever say you can't.
And if you know you can't,
you gotta make yourself.
I've been like this all night long.
Freezing cold, jitters.
(panting)
No, I'd be like, oh, it's hot.
Ooh, it's hot outside when it's below.
Train your thought.
If you sad, if you cry at anything.
- [Mark] You get depressed sometimes?
- Oh, honey, I was a self-harmer.
I used to self-harm.
In and out of psych hospitals.
- [Mark] Cut yourself?
- Okay, Let's go.
- Thank you guys for watching this video.
You can find me on Instagram.
Kelly underscore dot Peach.
And on Facebook, Kim left.
Thank you.
- [Mark] Thank you Peaches.
- Yeah, okay.
- Okay.
- [Mark] All right.
You ready?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Do you want
to put your purse down,
or do you want to leave it?
- No, I'm waiting for you
to click it, restart it.
- [Mark] I just did.
We're rolling.
So Peaches, tell me about your childhood.
You've had some time to calm
down since this morning.
You were wound up this morning.
- Yeah, it's a lot.
My childhood.
Some people look at my
childhood as like terrifying.
And I hear from everybody
who hears my story.
Oh, I would never look at
you as a person that been
through that or I would have never known,
or adults, oh I couldn't imagine my child
going through that.
They look at me such as a strong person,
always got it together, everything.
But really deep inside,
I harbored a lot of guilt
and responsibility for
what I've been through.
- [Mark] So tell me the basic story.
So at 12 years old?
- I'm going to get there.
So a little bit on me is.
I was born to the proud
parents of Angela and Jason.
From what I was told, my mother died
when I was two months old.
I was born and raised
in Stockton, California.
There, I lived with my grandmother,
who raised me to the best of her ability,
but it was a lot of complications.
I had to grow up a lot faster than
a lot of other people
and a lot of other kids.
My abuse?
Everybody says the whole trans
thing, me becoming who I am.
If you're gay, you're gay.
You know who you are.
I dislike when people say,
faggot, this and all that.
I hate the question.
Are you, were you, how did you know?
How did you find out?
Honey, your life is always written out.
- [Mark] You were born this way?
- Yes, it doesn't just come along.
- [Mark] You were
molested at six years old,
and that changed everything?
- No honey, but I was molested
on my eleventh birthday
by my older cousin,
later that night.
This happened around
morning time, actually.
And my grandmother left,
at this time I was living
in Stockton, on Clay
Street, my childhood home.
Yeah, it wasn't a home.
It was a crack house.
But anyway.
Yeah, I got raped and
it was kinda the most,
terrifying thing that
happened to me in my life.
But also the most,
- [Mark] Formative?
- No, that's not the word.
The, like the best thing basically.
- [Mark] Oh really?
- Yeah, because I re-look
at it every night.
It's not a day that goes by,
that I don't think about it,
because at the end of the day
that's what revolved around everything.
That night, oh honey.
That's the reason.
I feel like that's the
reason my deep inside.
I feel like if that night
would've never happened,
I wouldn't be here right now.
Honey, I'm 18 years old.
I just turned 18.
My birthday is 09/02/2002, baby.
I have no reason to lie.
I tell my niece, oh girl, you're not 18.
You're not 18, you're not 18, stop lying.
I have no reason to lie,
I just act and train myself
as an adult because
that's all I'm known to.
And yes, I'm a drug user.
My drug history started
off when I was young.
I got addicted to black-tar heroin first.
I mean, yes, alcohol, you
know, that's a regular drug.
Everybody is acquitted to
drinking alcohol and smoking weed,
but nobody really knows
more hardcore drugs
like crystal and heroin,
and party drugs as in molly and LSD.
But me growing up, my drug
of choice was crystal.
I didn't want to experience it,
but you see my grandma
doing it, helping her.
I learned to shoot up, well not myself,
but I had to learn to, you know,
'cause my grandma would be too high.
She'd be too high sometimes.
So I had to help her sometimes.
- [Mark] Your grandmother?
- Mm-hmm.
Tie her up.
- [Mark] And you were how old?
- I just started helping
her around twelve, thirteen.
But younger than that I
always looked like, what?
Put all needles together,
make sure everything nice.
And you know, I was like the second her.
When she not up to par, I'm there.
To anybody, 'cause that's
how, by the end of the day,
everybody in my family,
they look at my grandma
as a bad person because truth be told,
my grandmother was my first pimp.
- [Mark] She was your pimp?
- My first pimp.
- 2/03, after my eleventh birthday,
a day after my September 3rd, 2002.
Honey, I lived on Clay Street
in Stockton, California.
95206, my childhood home.
Clay Street, this way.
Aurora Street, the backstreet.
I started working Aurora.
Aurora, that was my first place.
- [Mark] At eleven years old?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Do you remember your first?
- I'm finna tell you.
My first trick I ever turned
was at 203 next morning.
After my rape, she came home.
Of course I'm in there trying
to clean up everything.
My feeling that I will never tell nobody,
but I'm gonna take it to the grave,
because I believe that's what happened.
I feel like she was too high
and set me up, set the rape up.
There's no other way for
me to think about it.
But I can't train myself
to think like that,
but that's just a
feeling I have in my head
because who else would have known
that I was in that house?
And how did they know everything?
But aside from that,
my first trick was
turned on Aurora Street.
And all I can remember from
it was the blood still.
But the pain was unbearable.
Me at eleven years old, my anus is.
This was a 18, 19, 20, 21 year old man.
He went to Edison High School.
Edison High School's on
Charter Way by Dollar General.
At this time, his genital was,
larger, like growth.
Mind you, I'd never done this before.
Never even played with
that or nothing like that.
Never experienced any
pain, like from the area.
Except for that's all I know
to use the bathroom, that's it.
It hurt.
It hurt so bad.
Ooh, like you just don't know like
how bad it hurt me as a person.
It's like getting burnt.
It's like getting burnt or
somebody like putting a knife.
Imagine that you have
a big bowel movement.
That hurts let alone.
Imagine someone sticking a knife in you.
And you just have to sit there, like.
You're fighting, you're fighting,
but sometimes you just give up.
In the beginning, I was giving
it all my eleven years old,
just thumping, ten toes.
And then he got ahold of me and then
from there I realized
it was no more fighting.
I screamed so loud, nobody came.
Nobody came and it was
kind of weird how me
and him was the only one in my
home when it was my birthday.
This happened on my birthday.
I'm just like, well, you know
when I walk the streets now and all that,
I just think of it when I have free time.
I'm just trying to put my life story
back together to get to where
I can make it make sense.
'Cause it's a lot of
shit that happened to me,
that's still happening, currently.
I can't imagine how I'm
getting treated like this,
when I do all I do for people.
My life is not easy.
After what brought me out
into being a prostitute willingly,
to go out there is that the fact
that my grandmother was able to do that
to me and everybody knew
and thought it was cool.
Why not let everybody, you know?
And then CPS got involved,
and she got her parental rights taken,
and whole bunch of stuff.
I got moved out of Stockton
and San Joaquin County.
But I kept going back.
Why?
The big question is, why?
Everybody who helps me,
why would you go back
to that situation when I'm
trying to give you more?
I'm trying to offer
you to get out of that.
The reason why I come back
to the streets every time?
It's not because of the drugs,
because I can't handle it.
And because I don't want a new life.
It's that that's what I generated from.
The streets, that's all I know.
- [Mark] It's what you know as love.
- [Peaches] That's what I know.
That's where I feel the most affectionate.
Like I got to the point where,
I've been in the streets so
long that, that's my family.
These bums out here?
They're scared of these bums.
Everybody scared of the
people who tweak out.
Ooh look at him, he's nasty,
feet dirty, black.
I look at them like y'all
look at y'all colleagues
in a billion, million dollar business.
- [Mark] So if Prince Charming
pulled up in a Mercedes-Benz
and wanted to take you to the square life?
- Oh I'mma use that nigga.
I'm gonna use him for every dime he got.
Period, stick to the game, baby.
No amount of money in the world,
no clean nigga in the world.
This is guaranteed, my life.
My hustle is guaranteed.
But I only use it to survival.
Right now I'm in survival mode.
If I had me somebody who made
sure I got my little dope,
and got me clothes and
clean shower everyday,
I wouldn't do that.
I mean, I would be with
him and stay with him,
but I'm going to just keep it real.
I wouldn't be loyal.
I've messed with somebody on the side.
I'm just keeping it real.
I can't be with the
same dick all day long.
The same person.
I gave that up when I chose this life.
I gave up reaching out to certain people
when I chose this life.
I gave up my family relationships.
I gave up true friendships.
I gave up my self-respect,
my level of self respect.
I gave up hunger.
You know the last time I ate?
I eat candy, that's my thing, candy.
That's what gets me going, candy.
- [Mark] And crystal meth.
- Let's not get things that keep me going.
Candy, crystal meth.
The reason why I keep
alcohol and crystal on me?
Crystal to keep me up and alert.
Alcohol to numb me from the coldness.
Honey, it's stuff I got to
deal with every day out here.
People want to kill me.
Honey, I hoe I in Oakland,
Richmond, San Jose, Stockton.
You hear the men outside?
Yelling and screaming.
You know who that is?
- [Mark] No.
- I don't either.
Guess what?
I heard Peaches.
So obviously when I go in there
I'm going to have to deal with something.
So when I go in there, I'm
not gonna have my shoes on.
Because you see where my feet like this?
- [Mark] Yeah.
- Crusted up, dirty.
Peeled up skin and not
taken care of, right?
But you see my up part?
Nice, right?
- [Mark] You're beautiful.
- Right, right, right.
- [Mark] You're spectacular.
- Okay, any day, right?
I would take off my shoes.
Honey, I can care less who comes up here.
At the end of the day,
as long as it's my
little documentary thing
gets out to other people.
To be honest with you,
you can keep the money.
I don't do this for the money.
But you give me money out of respect that,
'cause you know, I'm going,
gonna have to need it.
But guess what?
(door knock)
- It's me, Stephanie.
- [Mark] Hold on one sec.
Hey, I can edit this out.
- Yeah, keep rolling.
- [Mark] You're doing
a fucking amazing job.
- Hold on, hold on, keep it rolling,
'cause this is the real.
- [Mark] Hey Stephanie, what's up?
I'll be done in a second, I'll come down.
- Stephanie, come here.
- [Stephanie] This guy
was trying to fucking
- Girl, Stephanie, get in here.
Stephanie, get your ass in here.
- [Stephanie] And he
thinks there's a problem.
- Stephanie, come here.
Stephanie, Stephanie, come here.
Now.
Shut that door, sir.
Shut that door real quick.
[Stephanie] I'm going
to the lower Tenderloin
to get my cousin.
- Hold on, hold on.
That's not needed.
That's what you don't understand.
- [Stephanie] Your little
white friend on the bicycle.
The little fucking scrappy looking dude,
who's getting abusive with me.
Trying to hit me.
- This is what you have to understand.
- [Stephanie] If he hits me.
- Honey, they're not gonna
hit you with me, honey.
You've seen me in action before over you.
- [Stephanie] The thing
is, my cousin is down
in the lower Tenderloin from
New Orleans, my real cousin.
- Listen, listen, girl.
Okay, listen.
Hold on.
- [Stephanie] Let me do the interview.
- Wait, hold on.
I see that you're worked up right now.
But you have to understand
what we're doing right now.
You see we're hoes right?
- [Stephanie] Yes.
So you have to stick to the game.
We not supposed to be
talking to people like this.
We are doing this to help,
to let people know the real
will go on behind closed doors.
We're risking it and so are they.
Apparently he was looking for you or me,
but you already know how
I go down for you, right?
- [Stephanie] What he told me
was to bring you your shit.
- But you know how I go down?
You know how I go down with you, right?
When have I ever let
anyone lay a hand on you?
- [Stephanie] Okay, okay, I'll leave.
Well, here's your suitcase.
- That part.
- [Stephanie] All right, I'm going to go
sit on the back steps.
- Told you, right.
I said something, when I said something.
- [Mark] Your instincts are great.
- But guess what?
- [Mark] So you're talking
about your feet and your shoes.
- Oh, I'm taking 'em off, you know why?
'Cause I'll be damned
if somebody touch her.
I took her under my wing.
You see that?
She been wearing my clothes
all day everyday on.
I know she got her own clothes.
She got a place to sleep
every night, I don't.
But at the same time,
I'm willing to give up
me and my safety for her
'cause at the end of the day,
when I die I want everybody
in the fucking world to know
that I did everything I did
to not change everything,
but to make you feel
comfortable with yourself.
'Cause when I'm out here,
I want you to be resilient.
Look at it, blisters is red.
- [Mark] Your feet are
much better than most.
I don't doubt you work your ass off.
- The real, honey?
The pain comes from within.
You have to trust yourself.
If you're scared walking down the street,
you're not going to make no money.
If you don't make no money, you don't eat.
You don't sleep.
Me, I can't sleep.
I've been up two weeks and
counting, fourteen days.
Today's my fifteenth day, if I make it.
If you look up closely in my eyes,
they going like this,
jittering, jittering, jittering.
You look at my skin?
I'm ready now.
Ooh, honey, I just got out the hospital.
You know why?
- [Mark] What for?
- A stomach bug, honey.
You don't always have condoms.
But you don't always have a
predicament that you're in.
So it's either you have sex
with this trick with no condom,
or you don't have no place to sleep
when you're outside in the cold,
where you can get wrecked and killed.
Which one?
You pick.
You risk living with something.
Or, honey, I get checked up.
I stay teeth white, everything, honey.
No matter what I'm in.
But just know I will gladly do somebody
without protection because
my health comes first.
I'd rather live with something
than be dead and gone.
Because my work here on
this earth ain't done.
'Cause it's somebody out
there still who need my help.
Who needs somebody who been through it,
who know and experienced it,
who can tell you how to get out of it.
And if you can't get out of it,
I'm going to show you
how to work through it.
But right now I gotta use your bathroom,
'cause my stomach bug problem.
Honey, I don't have no underwear on.
But my stomach bug problem is,
you constantly shit on yourself.
- [Mark] Your talk has been amazing.
You speak beautifully about this.